President Trump has declared a national
emergency to get more federal money for
his long-promised border wall in the
White House Rose Garden on Friday the
president announced his plan to use
billions from military construction and
counter drug efforts to fund the wall
his move comes after Congress approved a
spending measure to avoid another
government shutdown that included 1.4
billion dollars for the wall far less
than mr. Trump had requested and it's
already coming under scrutiny with
multiple lawsuits filed to stop the
president's emergency declaration after
the announcement mr. Trump flew to his
Florida resort where he's spending the
weekend Errol Barnett is traveling with
the president
Erol good morning good morning look
while the fight that caused the
government shutdown is over the battle
over the president's emergency
declaration that it's just getting
heated up now even though the President
signed the congressional spending bill
his Rose Garden announcement of this
national emergency is likely to be
challenged in the courts which could
potentially end up all the way at the
Supreme Court I didn't need to do this
but I'd rather do it much faster
president Trump conceded his impatience
with Congress led him to declare a
national emergency in order to secure
border wolf funding and crafted a
hyperbolic interpretation of immigrants
pouring into the u.s. we have an
invasion of drugs and criminals coming
into our country according to US Customs
and Border Protection apprehensions are
down 76 percent from a record high 19
years ago and the number of undocumented
immigrants living in the u.s. is at its
lowest point since 2004 they say walls
don't work walls work a hundred percent
the administration is planning to spend
roughly eight billion dollars to spend
234 miles of steel wall in addition to
the one point four billion dollars
agreed to by Congress 600 million
dollars will come from the Treasury
Department and the rest will be from the
Pentagon two point five billion that
would have been used to fight drug
trafficking and 3.6 billion taken from
military construction projects but I
won't go into details but didn't sound
too important to me he's been
embarrassed
and his base needs to be fed
California's Democratic governor Gavin
Newsom is filing a lawsuit to challenge
the emergency declarations Donald Trump
will see you in court the American Civil
Liberties Union announced it would also
file a suit and House Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler called
for a hearing to investigate the serious
constitutional and statutory issues the
declaration raises he gets away with
this president's become much more
powerful sadly we'll be sued and sadly
it'll go through a process and happily
we'll win
I think mr. Trump dismissed criticism
suggesting he is setting a bad precedent
saying previous presidents have declared
national emergencies the people that say
we create precedent well what do you
have fifty-six or a lot of times well
that's creating precedent and many of
those are far less important than having
a border now three Texas landowners and
an environmental group have already
filed a lawsuit challenging this
emergency declaration they say they were
told by the government a border wall
could extend through their properties if
money was made available this year
Anthony Errol Barnett thanks very much
Earl